on and even functions right on an even
are words which describe kinds of
symmetry
kinds of symmetry
and the reason why i'm coming up with
them now is because as you've noticed
when we graphed all the trig functions
they all exhibit various kinds of
symmetry sometimes multiple kinds okay
so before i get to this
let me just give you the classic example
of iodine functions and then we'll fit
our understanding of trig into it okay
so draw with me a small set of axes
actually two of them
two small sets of axes
right these don't have to be um these
don't have to be huge or beautiful just
enough to see some bare geometric
features okay
so
we're going to very quickly draw two
kinds of functions with two kinds of
symmetry okay
so we're going to do y equals x squared
and we're going to do y equals x cubed
these are very very easy but you'll see
why i've chosen these in a second
y equals x squared we know what this
looks like all right
y equals x squared it's the familiar
parabola okay now i don't understand
what's happening here with the symmetry
i'm going to phrase this a little bit
differently i've said y equals x squared
and y equals xq because that's how we're
used to hearing it okay but a more
technical way of saying these things
just slightly more technical
is to say instead of y to say f of x now
this is not the first time you've seen
it but in case it's been a little while
f just stands for function right and it
means that over here
is something that you put x into it's a
function of x okay you can have
functions of anything functions of time
functions of speed functions of position
displacement and on and on
i put x into there so it's a function of
x this is also a function of x i could
call them different things if it doesn't
matter okay
now you can see that this thing is
symmetrical right so for instance if i
took um a value like x equals 2
and i draw that up to a certain value
you get 4
and if i go to the opposite side the y
axis and i go to -2
and i draw my point up i will get the
same value right so the way of saying
that
with this language is to say that f of
two right my x value is two so that's
why it appears where the x is
is equal to f of
minus two okay and actually i can take
this for any value of x on this
particular function because it's
symmetrical all the way it's not like it
gets to you know
a million and five and then decide but
stuff that i don't know is symmetrical
anymore all values of x right it's going
to do that so i can state this generally
i don't just have to put particular
values i can say f of x equals
f of minus x for any value of x right
that's what gives this so we call well
this is reflectional symmetry isn't it
it's symmetrical about
the y-axis okay and we call this even
symmetry in a second i'll ask you why
let's come over to this guy right in
fact i think you just drew one of these
didn't you yeah so what you've got is
this
you've got this shape in here it levels
out and it's flat right there unlike tan
which blows through the axis at a
gradient this blows through with zero
okay now there's still symmetry here
there's still symmetry here but it's not
the same kind okay for instance i take
the same value two okay and you go up to
the corresponding
value up here right it's going to be 2
cubed which is 8.
now when i take the same value on the
other side and i go to minus 1 minus 2
okay well unlike here i'm not going up
to the same value 8 clearly
but what i am going to is
the same value but negative right
because minus 2 or cubed of course is
minus 8.
okay so how would i say this look at
that statement we made over on the left
right yeah go ahead f of negative x is
equal to negative
okay i'm going to come to that in a
second i just want a statement from
these numbers right
f of t
is eight
we'll get to the generalization in a
second
and that's equal to
minus f of
minus two okay now
excuse me you can see this minus sign i
could kick him over here if i wanted i
can multiply both sides by minus one
it's the same statement
like
so okay because f of two is eight so
this is b minus eight which is of course
the same as f of minus two i might say
so now if i state this generally um i
generally do it the other way around i
would say f of minus x is equal to minus
f of x
okay so what i've got here is not
reflection or symmetry right it's not
reflecting across there it's not even
reflecting across here okay in fact what
i've got is rotational symmetry
around the origin can you see that if i
were to take this part up here in the
first quadrant and then just turn it
around you get this down here in the
third quadrant okay
so here
reflectional
okay and we call that even symmetry
or it's an even function
and over here we have rotational
symmetry
and we call that
odd
okay now there are a variety of reasons
why they are called odd and even
symmetry but i said i would ask you a
second ago why you think they're called
or never there's one reason which just
jumps out at you which i've picked this
is these two examples specifically for
this yeah
thank you so you're like
even
oh now ordinarily i would frown i'm
thinking oh look i found one example and
another that's it that's enough to
generalize the pattern but you might be
starting to think hold on a second
i said this is x squared right but on a
different scale
this would be x to the fourth right i
just have to stretch things out this way
or x to the 6 or x to the 8th or x 1024
right they're all actually going to look
pretty much like that just steeper
and so they're all going to exhibit the
same symmetry because they have even
powers
you make the same argument over here
right if this is x 5 x 7 9 1023
they're all odd
degrees right so therefore you're going
to get odd symmetry
now there's the idea there's the idea
okay